اَنَا انا انا إِبْرِيقُ الشَّايْ
أَمِيلُ هُنَا ...وأميل هنا
أَصُبُّ الشَّاي لاَ أحَدْ سِوَايْ
وأُتْقِنُ أَيْضًا يَا كَتَاكِيتْ  سَرْدَ الحِكَايَاتْ
يَوْمًا عُصْفُورةْ قَمْورَةْ
وَجَدَتْ مَصَّاصَةْ بِالشَّارِعْ
أَكَلَتْهَا مِنْ غَيْرِ سُؤَالْ  فَبَكَتْ مِنْ أَلَمٍ وَمَواجِعْ
فَبَكَتْ مِنْ أَلَمٍ وَمَواجِعْ
جَاءَ طَبِيبٌ يَا أَطْفَالْ كشَفَ عَلَيْهَا ثُمَّ قَالْ
هَذَا خَطَأٌ َيا عُصْفُورَةْ
خَطَأٌ خَطَأٌ
قال الطبيب للعصفورة سَأَصِفُ دَوَاءً لَكِ فِى الحَالْ
سَأَصِفُ دَوَاءً لَكِ فِى الحَالْ
قَالَ بِحُبٍ حَتَّى نَحْذَرْ
إِنَّ الكُلَّ يُحِبُّ السُّكَّرْ
لَكِنْ لاَ نَأْكُلْ مَكْشُوفًا  وَلْتَسْأَلِيْ إِبْرِيقَ الشّاَيْ
إبريق الشاي إبريق الشاي
اَنَا انا انا إِبْرِيقُ الشَّايْ  أَمِيلُ هُنَا ...وأميل هنا
أَصُبُّ الشَّاي لاَ أحَدْ سِوَايْ وأُتْقِنُ أَيْضًا يَا كَتَاكِيتْ
كَانْ يَا مَا كَانْ عُصْفُورٌ أَحْمَرْ
زَقْزَقَ فَوْقَ الغُصْنِ الأَخْضَرْ
وَفَرَاشَاتٍ بِالأَلْوَانِ
لَكِنْ فَجْأَةْ أَمْرٌ يَحْصُلْ  تَهْتَزُّ الأَرْضُ وتُزَلْزَلْ
فَلأَنَّ الفِيلُ بِخُرْطُومِهْ  يَقْفِزُ بِسَعَادَةْ وَيُهَلِّلْ
فِى أَرْضِ الغَابَةْ العُشْبِيَّةْ
الفِيلُ يُغَنِّى أغْنِيَةْ
ويَقُولُ اَنَا اَنَا مَعَ خُرْطُومِى نُشْبِهُ شَكْلْ إِبْرِيقُ الشَّايْ
إبريق الشاي إبريق الشاي
اَنَا انا انا إِبْرِيقُ الشَّايْ  أَمِيلُ هُنَا ...وأميل هنا
أَصُبُّ الشَّاي لاَ أحَدْ سِوَايْ
وأُتْقِنُ أَيْضًا يَا كَتَاكِيتْ سَرْدَ الحِكَايَاتْ